we require so much of our politicians
post Trump you know be before Trump I'm
old enough to remember like Scott Walker
as the front runner yeah I really like
Scott Walker I think he's brilliant but
he's not exactly Mr Personality uh you
know when it comes to Charisma that was
fine for the Republican party for a time
they were like yeah we might do that
let's let's try them out you know um
they nominated Mitt Romney he's not a
walking ball of Charisma either uh John
McCain wasn't either you know we could
keep going mhm George W bush wasn't he
had he had charm though he he had some
charm and baseball yeah but it was sneak
up on you but anyway um none of them was
in Trump's field of like commanding a
room and the celebrity factor and the
humor he's a standup comedian as you
know you appreciate that Talent none of
them had that so until Trump came around
we our standards were lower on how much
we needed to be entertained you know
like entertain me dance for me that's
how we are now it's like oh Ronda
Sanders you don't make me laugh you're
not clever you're not funny you're just
a good leader when did I don't want that
you're just functional defending the
Constitution making sure the government
can't inject us with I didn't sign
up for this I paid a $25 cover charge
make me laugh anyway so I think I
think he they were all up against it
with Trump and and it's it won't be
until Trump exit stage left on his own
volition or because he gets called home
up above that there's going to be room
for another person in this you know race
for the White House or this sort of
presidential Politics on the on the
right what what what would you make of
the argument that in essence this was
the best thing that could have happened
to the Democrats or assuming that you're
correct about this and Trump now runs
the table that all right you have the
weakest candidate you the court cases we
know a certain amount of people hate him
people think he's Hitler da D like this
is what they wanted there are no new
voters there something like that I guess
I don't totally buy it I get it I see
the smart people making the argument
people I really respect and follow
but uh I've got my doubts because
there's no one stronger than Trump he's
just extremely strong and resilient like
whatever you throw at the man it doesn't
hurt him and that wouldn't necessarily
be true for anybody else it wouldn't be
true for anybody else but everyone else
is like Mortal and Trump is like
something else I don't know what he is I
realize he's mortal but I just saying
like he's got this incredible ability to
resist everything the Teflon Dawn and I
don't think anybody else has that you
know other controversies other scandals
stick to everyone else they're not a
walking ball of chaos and Charisma I
guess he's both and it's worked for him
so I can see the argument that Trump's
the only one who can do it that the
media do you think the media was going
to let Ronda santis saunter into the
White House they definitely were going
to be bringing up girls from the high
school at which he taught saying he Meed
me or he looked at me the wrong way I
mean madeup stuff but they the
they play dirty God they fight very
dirty look what they did to BR Kavanaugh
you know this a sweet guy Supreme Court
Justice they wanted he's a drunk he's a
serial rapist seral rapist yeah I mean
come on so they're going to do this to
anybody and I I mean I can see the
argument that Trump's the only one who's
played this game won the game no matter
what you throw at him he Ste he stays
standing and he's just tough as a mofo
so I I don't know if I if I would say
they've nominated the one most likely to
be defeated I'm not sure if I believe
that